hey guys it's Jan here we all know that
Marvel aren't wants to skimp when it
comes to loading their movies and TV
shows with Easter eggs or references to
the wider Marvel Universe and season 1
of Jessica Jones is certainly no
exception in fact it's positively laden
with Easter eggs and callbacks now that
all 13 episodes of Jessica Jones are out
on Netflix I've put together as many of
those eggs and references as I could
find in this video I'm sure you'll have
spotted other cool ones too so do share
those in the comments below and just a
quick reminder there will be spoilers
ahead so if you're not ready for that
check out my non-spoiler review of the
show right here the very first scene of
the series looks like it was almost torn
straight from the first issue of the
alias Jessica Jones comics with Jessica
tossing an angry client straight through
the glass pane in the front door of her
alias investigations office the show
also makes lots of references to
Jessica's superhero past in the comics
for instance when trish puts forward
jewel as a superhero name and Jessica
dismisses it is a really [ __ ]
strippers name in the comics when
Jessica is under kilgrave's mind-control
he tells her to put on her [ __ ] costume
in other words her superhero suit and
the white spandex costume with a purple
jewel that Trish reveals in episode 5
has obvious similarities to the costume
Jessica Waters jewel in the comics also
the mask that Trish puts on could be a
nod to Jessica's other comic book
identity as nitrous for which she wore
another costume and mask though that
mask was a different color to the one
Trish was and I'll come back to Trish's
desire to be a superhero a bit later oh
and when Jessica turned the mask around
so it was back to front on Trish and
teased her about how she'd fight like
that it felt like the show was poking a
little fun at daredevil there's also a
subtle nod to the white and blue colors
of jewels costume in the light shades in
Jessica's apartment block which are
white with a thin blue line around them
during conversations jessica has with
Luke Cage and young Trish there's
mention of Jessica getting her powers
from the car accident which killed her
biological family and the flashback
scenes of the car accident were Jessica
fights with her brother Phillip which
leads to family arguments and a
collision with a truck a very
reminiscent of
seems an alias issue 22 in the accident
which happens in the comic Jessica is
exposed to radioactive chemicals so it's
interesting that one of the streets
Jessica recites is called cobalt Lane
perhaps a nod to cobalt Chemical a New
York chemical corporation in Marvel
Comics
by the way Higgins Drive which is
another of the streets Jessica recite
could be a nod to Nigel Higgins a
British version of The Punisher and of
course the Punisher himself will be
appearing in daredevil season 2 Owen the
Mickey Mouse at one of kilgrave's men
takes into Jessica's former home is a
nod not only to Disney who owned Marvel
but also to the comic books and the trip
to Disney World that Jessica's family
were taking when their car crashed when
Jessica's photographing Luke in Episode
one he's wearing his signature colors
yellow and blue in this case a yellow
t-shirt and blue jeans as the Jessica's
relationship with Luke and their first
sex scene that follows the same story
from alias issue 1 and in episode 7 when
Jessica goes looking for Luke at his bar
the bartender says to her that you love
him you just want to have his baby which
is a reference to the comics where
Jessica does in fact have a baby girl
called Danielle with Luke in the same
scene there's also a nice nod to
Jessica's flying skills in the comics
when the bartender tells her you know
what happens when you burn a bridge you
had to learn how to swim or fly in alias
issue 23 when jessica discovers she can
fly for the first time she's not able to
control it and falls in the Hudson River
where she nearly drowns before being
saved by Thor by the way Luke Cage gets
to say his comic-book catchphrase sweet
Christmas for the first time in episode
3 while he's in bed but Jessica and
later again in episode 6 when they're
both searching for Antoine in that same
scene when the guard dogs arrive Luke
says he'll handle the dogs as sharpteeth
or his speciality this is a nice nod to
cottonmouth he was sharpened teeth and
is one of luke cage's antagonists in the
comics in terms of Luke's powers the
show alludes to the origin of these in
the comics when he says to Jessica that
he received his powers as a result of an
experiment there seemed to be more hints
about that experiment when Jessica hands
Luke the flash drive which Reaver buried
and killgrave made Jessica dig up after
all we already know that that drive
contains videos of experiments on
children Jessica also mentions there are
other files on there that she didn't
look at also notice that the flash drive
is yellow
Luke's signature color I'm guessing we
get to see what's on that drive in the
upcoming Luke Cage series the fan who
approaches Trish and says I liked you
with your red hair is a reference back
to her character Patsy Walker in the
comics who had red hair
in fact in episode 11 we get to see the
young Trish wearing a red wig during a
flashback scene which also features the
intro from her TV show as a child star
it's Patsy and that fan who liked
Trish's red hair is carrying what looks
like a modernized version of Patsy
Walker volume 1 issue 26 which was
published in 1950 in the show Trish
wants to Don a cape and save the world
and in the episode 11 flashback scene I
just mentioned the young Trish's mother
tells a hospitalised Jessica Jones that
I know you must be confused right now
but everything's going to be okay Patsy
is going to save you all of which could
be a hint that maybe in the future we'll
get to see Trish's Hellcat Patsy
Walker's comic book alter-ego in the
comics however Patsy Walker only has a
bit of interaction with Jessica Jones
when she applies for the job of nanny to
Jessica's daughter Danielle actually it
feels like Trish in the show has taken
on the role of Carol Danvers aka Captain
Marvel who is Jessica's best friend in
the comics of course Captain Marvel is
getting her own film in the MCU which is
why they didn't want her character in
the TV series by the way although the
Baxter hemodialysis machine does exist
in the real world its inclusion in
Jessica Jones feels like it has a little
added significance as Robert Baxter aka
Mad Dog is Patsy's former husband in the
comics kilgrave's alter-ego is a purple
man and the comics is constantly
referenced throughout the TV show for
example in the use of purple and the
opening credits with purple lighting
scattered throughout numerous scenes
kilgrave wearing a purple shirt in the
final two episodes and his face popping
with purple veins when he yells stop in
the finale there's also a verbal mention
of the color purple when kilgrave's
victims are first interviewed one of
them says kilgrave gave him a purple
staff and hold into stick it which seems
like a play on the moment
comics when the purple man goes into a
rage and orders Jessica to kill
daredevil with some choice words about a
rusty pipe and Daredevils ass as the
kilgrave's name there's lots of lovely
jokes about that throughout the series
in Episode three when Jessica goes into
a grocery store you can hear a guy on
the radio say have you ever heard form
or made-up name than killgrave this is a
little inside joke as although in the TV
show kilgrave is an alias or made-up
name for Kevin Thompson in the comics
zebediah killgrave is the characters
real name and his alias is the purple
man the joke continues in episode 9 when
Jessica towards kilgrave about why he
picked that name asking if murder corpse
was already taken and again in episode
13 Claire temple jokes he should be
called snuff carcass by the way I liked
the what doesn't kill us makes a
stranger quipped that Jessica makes to
Simpson which is actually a line the
Joker says in the Dark Knight which
feels appropriate given the psychotic
Joker vibe that David Tennant's kilgrave
gives off and there's even a clever
Doctor Who Easter Egg referencing David
Tennant's time as a Tenth Doctor when
Jessica says to killgrave in episode 8
you're not 10 anymore
and kilgrave's words send the picture
save the junkie or an echo of the often
repeated phrase save the cheerleader
save the world from the TV series heroes
and there's a funny Star Wars joke about
obi-wan Kenobi and kilgrave's powers
when he and Jessica enter the hostage
House NYPD cop and former Special Ops
agent will Simpson is the MC news
version of the comics Frank Simpson aka
nuke who underwent a super-soldier
program similar to the one which created
Captain America and there's a strong
similarity between the look of actor
will travail who plays will Simpson and
Jessica Jones and Chris Evans who plays
Steve Rogers aka Captain America in the
MCU
in the comics one of nukes
distinguishing features is the American
flag he has tattooed on his face and is
a cool nod to this in the show with the
American flag on Simpson's lighter like
in the show
in the comics nuke is given red white
and blue pills and he experiences the
same cravings for the red pills which
have similar effects
Kozlov who gave him the pills and the TV
series is a bit of a mystery as there
isn't a direct comic book counterpart
for
however there is a scientist called
Michel Kozlov who appeared in the
strange tales and were monsters 12
series later Trish discovers that Kozlov
works for IgH which he says is
mysterious private research corporation
and she's seen investigating it at the
end of the series and there are hints
that the origins of Jessica's super
powers may have something to do with IgH
2 as Trish's mother Dorothy reveals they
paid for Jessica's medical bills after
the car accident
maybe IgH which trish says is an acronym
for nothing in the show is actually an
allusion to the comic books MGH aka
mutant growth hormone the MCU can't
reference MGH itself as Fox have the
film rights to music related stuff but
perhaps IgH could stand for in human
growth hormone as the Inhumans are
already part of the MCU in both agents
of shield and are set to have their own
movie - I'd love to know any theories
you've got about what the mysterious IgH
is by the way it's interesting that when
Jessica is fighting Simpson in her
apartment she slams him repeatedly into
her refrigerator which he then pulls on
top of him this feels like a deliberate
swipe at and reversal with a twist of
the trope that comic book writer Gail
Simone called women in refrigerators
Simone drew up a list of female comic
book characters who've been actually put
it deep Howard raped or cut up and stuck
in the refrigerator the idea originates
from a Green Lantern comic where Kyle
rayna's girlfriend is murdered and
stuffed into a refrigerator by alluding
to this trope the show seems to be
making a point about its treatment of
female characters and saying that nobody
puts Jessica Jones in a refrigerator and
it's interesting that Claire temple who
we've already seen in season 1 of
daredevil plays a big part in the final
episode of Jessica Jones and it's
curious that Claire made a point of
saying that she's no on sidekick while
talking to Malcolm Marvel didn't allow
the daredevil series to use the name
night nurse or Rosario Dawson's
character Claire as there were potential
plans to use night nurse in the movies
maybe clothes words could therefore hint
at bigger plans ahead for night nurse in
the MCU or is it just a pointed comment
about female characters in Marvel other
character
you've been changed in the comics
include jeryn hogarth and malcolm
Hogarth
the shark-like lawyer played by
carrie-anne moss is actually a male
lawyer in the comic that has a strong
connection to iron fist so it'll be
interesting to see what role carrier mas
gets in the iron fist series planned for
Netflix in the Jessica Jones comics
Malcolm pops up from time to time as an
annoying fanboy who wants to help out
Jessica in the show he's a much more
significant character with new
storylines however the final scene in
the series where he answers Jessica's
phone brings to mind scenes where he
does the same in the alias comics and it
wouldn't be a Marvel production without
a cameo from Stan Lee who pops up in a
framed picture at the police station
also pinned up at the police station you
can spot the newspaper cutting for
journalist Ben Eurex Union allied
corruption scandal article in The New
York bulletin from daredevil season 1
there's also an amusing reference to
Grey's Anatomy which is on the
disney-owned Channel ABC when Jessica
pretends to be a nurse and claims she's
previously worked at Seattle Grace
Hospital and the title of episode 8 aka
WWJD is likely short for what would
Jessica do which is a nice play on the
usual meaning of the acronym what would
Jesus do and the yacht named goldfish
that kilgrave plans to leave town on is
a nice nod to the comic book series aka
goldfish written and drawn by Brian
Michael Bendis who of course created the
character of Jessica Jones with artists
Michael gaydar's speaking of Ben
disengage there are more allusions in
the show to their alias comics for
example Reubens death in Jessica's bed
has a similar feel to the vision of
Scott lying dead in her bed that kill
Grove makes her see in alias issue 27
and the supermax prison Jessica wants to
get herself locked up in is likely the
equivalent of the comic books raft
prison which is housed on Rikers Island
and when ho Gough says to Jessica that
Supermax is full of top-shelf perverts
cannibals and serial killers who make
mosaics with their victims fingernails
these kind of feel like allusions to
high-powered criminals like killgrave
himself Barron blurred and jigsaw who
are all in jail in the raft in the alias
comics and kilgrave's use of
mind-control to win a card game in
episode 6 reminds me of when he took
over a casino in the comic series
supervillain team-up Moe docks 11 and
the final showdown when killgrave orders
everyone
terminal to kill each other is
strikingly similar to seen in the final
alias comic when kilgrave orders
everyone to beat up the person to their
left until they're dead and of course
there are plenty of nods to Marvel's
next movie Captain America Civil War
with the show making various references
to how superheroes fit into society you
can sense the conflict that's still
brewing between people with and without
superpowers for example during a radio
talk show we hear when Jessica visits a
grocery store one caller talks about
there being more sightings of
superheroes since those guys quote save
the city and the caller also mentions
all the mess superheroes create for
everyone else there's also the subplot
with Audrey Eastman who wants to avenge
her mother's death in the Battle of New
York so she tricks Jessica into doing a
PI job for her only to try and kill her
thus far as each man's concerned people
with powers of freaks not gifted and in
that same storyline there are allusions
to specific MCU characters when Jessica
mentions the big green guy and the flag
waver in other words the Hulk and
Captain America oh and when Jessica
first tries to abduct kilgrave a kid
runs by in the park wearing a Captain
America costume again the show's
references to revealing superhero
identities fits in with a Civil War
setup for example in the first episode
when Jessica lifts up a car the driver
stresses to out her she replies that
she's not hiding and nobody cares anyway
as they just want to feel safe so she
also adds I'd rather call you crazy than
admit that I can lift this car or melt
your insides with my laser eyes later
during a conversation with Luke Jessica
again says she's not hiding but adds
she's not advertising either and Luke
points out that being a hero just puts a
target on your back in other Marvel
references when Jessica recommends
another private investigator to Luke
Cage she named drops Angela del Toro aka
white tiger who appears in the daredevil
comics in episode 8 wh IH world news
appears on TV to report on the hostage
standoff
whi H is a Marvel regular and it's TV
news stories have appeared in daredevil
agents of shield Avengers age of Ultron
the Incredible Hulk and I'm
- and there's another nod to Avengers
age of Ultron when Jessica says go to
sleep when she takes out a guy who's
attacking her because kilgrave's mind
controlling him in age of Ultron Scarlet
Witch hexes Bruce banners mind sending
him on a rampage as the Hulk and Iron
Man tries to bring him back by hammering
his head while repeating the words go to
sleep and in Episode six Jessica Scott's
at the loanshark circs thinks he's
called I can which is funny as Carl
Icahn is a real-life investor who once
tried to take over Marvel also Keebler
circus pops up on a sign behind Wendy in
Episode nine qiblah Circus was later
known as a Tybalt circus and Clint
Barton aka Hawkeye and the Hulk
among others were members at various
points and in episode 10 we hear that
hopes aborted fetus with kilgrave's DNA
was sent to hammond labs for testing
which could be the same hammond labs
from the comics that Robbie Baldwin aka
speedball interned out now what other
Easter eggs references and callbacks did
you spot in Jessica Jones and which are
your favorites and I'd also love to know
what you saw to the series as a whole I
look forward to reading your comments
below and thanks in advance for sharing
and liking this video if you're a fan of
comic book TV shows you might want to
check out my videos here 15 things you
probably didn't know about daredevil and
10 things you probably didn't know about
the flash do subscribe for more of mine
easter egg videos things you didn't know
movie reviews and more thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay superhero lovers